candidates for governor in nevada square
off
joe lombardo joey gilbert dean heller
john lee and gee nora this is your local
election headquarters nevada race for
governor the republican primary debate
good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight for our republican gubernatorial
primary debate we are just off the las
vegas strip here at the klas studios
this is airing and streaming across the
state of nevada here in las vegas as
well as at ktvn2 in reno i'm denise
valdez of klas-tv and joining us tonight
are steve sibelius who is the politics
and government editor at the las vegas
review journal along with vanessa murphy
who is an investigative reporter here at
klas
the five republicans standing on the
stage tonight have met our eligibility
requirements joining us are clark county
sheriff joe lombardo attorney joey
gilbert north las vegas mayor john lee
former senator dean heller and venture
capitalist guinora
so here are the rules for tonight's
debate each candidate will get 60
seconds to answer a question the
candidate will then get 30 seconds to
answer if there's a follow-up or perhaps
a rebuttal and if a clarification is
needed they will have an additional 15
seconds now we will remind the
candidates throughout the night of those
times the sound of a bell will ring when
their time is up
and that's what the bell will sound like
let's get steve started with our first
question tonight thanks denise welcome
gentlemen let's get right to the
questions 19 children and two adults
were killed at a texas elementary school
yesterday mr lombardo you are first to
answer this question and you have 60
seconds what would you do to protect
children and staff in schools from mass
shootings like this one
well thank you steve and first and
foremost thank you for channel 8 for
bringing us together tonight to
express our views on whatever the
subject matter may be
and first and foremost my condolences go
out to the victims the families
and the community in texas it's a tragic
event similar to what occurred here
locally on one october so i've lived
that experience and i know what they're
going through in that space
but the question is is what will we do
reference that type of tragedy moving
forward or what can we do as in the
position of governor
well first and foremost what i have
learned through my experience in law
enforcement is the mental health
services we are lacking the commonality
on most of these
tragic shootings on these mass shootings
is the nexus being
mental health
and the lack of resources to address the
individuals that who have been
identified to have deficiencies who may
cause harm into the future and
addressing that and second school safety
all the mechanisms to put in place to
address school safety in a more robust
level
mr omaro a 30-second follow-up you
mentioned mental health
where do you think you'll find the money
to devote additional resources to mental
health in the state well what i've
learned in trips to san antonio where
they have best practices with that
because a significant amount of calls
for service that we respond to on a
daily basis involves mental health
individuals out of san antonio and what
they did was a public private
partnership to bring that money and
resources together because they are the
experts in the field and allocation
reallocation and auditing of his
existing revenue streams within the
state budget all right thank you mr
lombardo mr gilbert you are next you
also have 60 seconds what would you do
to protect children and staff and
schools from mass shootings like the one
in texas
well my heart goes out to the families
that lost loved ones it's absolutely
devastating
the mental health issue in the state of
nevada were last in the nation for
mental health
resources for children teenagers and
adults are lacking in las vegas where we
have two mental health facilities are
overstaffed and don't have enough
resources we need to do a better job
there
governor sysolak and the democrats
defunded school police by 30 million
dollars in 2019 there's roughly 146
officers you know for 54 000 employees
320 000 kids at 366 campuses and so we
need to do a better job i would fully
fund public safety and you know there's
so much corruption bloat and waste in
this government when nevada got the
second largest amount of coronavirus
stimulus relief funds in the nation uh
we have the money we're just not using
it properly so i would use the people's
money to secure our most prized asset
our children
and and uh mr gilbert another 30-second
follow-up for you
you say there's waste in the in the
state government where exactly would you
find the funds to fully fund the school
police for example just in a casual
review of clark county school budget
clark county and washer county i found
nearly you know 30 35 percent could be
saved by privatizing services to blow it
alone administrators as i've said before
you could literally go through them and
say duck duck goose duck duck goose and
if those people want to stay uh work
with kids they can go in the classroom
on a teacher's salary that also fixes
the teacher shortage but the money's
there it's just being wasted thank you
mr gilbert mr heller you are next you
have 60 seconds what would you do to
protect students and staff in schools
from violence first of all steve yeah
first of all steve thank you denise and
vanessa for having us here channeling
for the opportunity to have this
conversation i'm glad we started out uh
with this particular question because i
think we do need to acknowledge the
tragedy that did occur in texas this is
the 27th 27th school shooting this year
and this is continuing on and on and on
and one of the problems that we have is
that you take a look at the washington
post washington post did a story this
week on the clark county school district
down here and how dangerous it is and
the teachers are the ones that are being
targeted now with clubs with knives with
sexual assault even students raping
teachers this has to change it's time to
break up this school district i'll
i think mesquite ought to have their own
school district boulder city ought to
have their summerlin should have all
theirs this is too big and and we are
fortunate that we haven't had this kind
of tragedy occur in our school district
here in las vegas thank you mr heller uh
mr lee you are next same question in 60
seconds what would you do to protect
thank you very much first i'm as sad as
these gentlemen are here too at being a
father
and a grandfather and a great
grandfather i don't know how these
families are going to be able to recover
from this accident this incident that
happened in this country
we have things that are called soft
targets where people can just walk in
and do whatever they want with a gun
there's nothing to protect the children
our stores and and places that are soft
targets i also believe in school safety
too i think there's doors you can walk
in here this one doesn't unlock until
you go through this door you get a
chance to look at people i think one
entry makes the most sense to me
i know in elko they have fathers up
there that are now coming into the
school just walking around and observing
and taking care of some of the
responsibility away from the school
district i think we need to include also
when we talk about mental health more in
parent involvement in what's going on at
our schools and i also believe we need
to break up school district and get more
inclusive with the cities into the
school districts thank you mr lee mr
nora same question 60 seconds what would
you do to protect schools you know last
night as i was feeling so bad for these
parents and all these families out there
and praying for them
i thought i'm a venture capitalist how
do i solve problems because that's what
i'm here for
i want to start something called the
battle-born marshals
and battle-born marshals are going to
report to the department of safety and
they're going to go out to the 664th
schools
and they're going to be marshals the way
we the same way we have them on our
airlines and that's how we're going to
define them from these lunatics that go
in
and prey on children
thank you very much um a 15-second uh
follow-up for all the candidates will go
in the same order uh are there any
restrictions
on the ownership or possession of
firearms that you think would help this
situation mr lombardo 15 seconds
no i don't i mean this is about age-old
question is the firearm the fault or is
the person holding the firearm
i have been i'm different than the rest
of the candidates i don't support a
constitutional carry i think training
should go along with it i do support the
evaluation of a person's mental capacity
and ability to possess a gun and i also
support background checks not universal
but regular background checks associated
with removing an individual who is
prohibited and may or may not need to
possess a gun thank you for that answer
mr gilbert same same question any
restrictions on firearms you think would
help this situation no i believe we have
enough gun laws and these always seem to
happen on gun-free zones we need more
involvement from the parents we need
open campuses so people can come in and
see what's going on more contact with
these students this is a mental health
issue and gun laws aren't going to solve
mr heller same question 15 seconds do
you support any restrictions on firearm
news
i think we've proven in chicago in new
york city that that excessive tax or gun
laws do not work
no i would not do that i don't want to
stand here in front on this studio and
negotiate away our second amendment
rights here in the state of nevada i
support them i continue to support them
and i'm an a-plus with the nra sounds
good thank you mr heller mr lee same
question also i i agree with these
gentlemen on this i do know that we need
to do what we can to make sure that
people have the right to carry again to
protect themselves i know schools are a
little bit different but there's a lot
of soft targets in the world i think we
should make sure we can get if people
want to protect themselves be able to
get a ccw license quicker to be able to
support themselves and other people if
they need the help thank you mr lee mr
north
i think that we need more organizations
like dads and schools to be involved and
help us and shout out to pastor martinez
thank you very much sir i appreciate it
denise
another topic that our viewers might be
talking about around the dinner table is
inflation it is at a 40-year high and in
our eight news now the hill emerson
college republican primary poll more
than 44 percent said the economy that
includes jobs inflation taxes that is
the top issue this election now the
inflation rate is up more than eight
percent
gas prices are up more than a dollar
sixty a gallon food price is up nearly
eleven percent and listen to this the
average rent for a three-bedroom
apartment here in las vegas is up 28
mr gilbert you are first on this
question tonight what would your plan be
as governor to curb inflation in our
state and as a reminder you have 60
seconds
well that's you know a great question
unfortunately the problem isn't here in
nevada it's in dc where they're printing
money like it's you know growing on a
tree um inflation is actually much
higher than eight percent as well and at
the end of the day we need to do things
like not shut our economy down which
should never happened especially for the
amount of time it did
that was not necessary i never would
have shut this day today and absolutely
the run to santa's to the west i would
have stayed open i wouldn't have shed a
business a school a church i definitely
would have tied any doctors hands but at
the end of the day you know we've got to
be open for business we need to have
less regulation less tax here we need to
be a business friendly state so that
companies want to come here but it's all
going to also come down to our schools
our schools are 50th in the nation for a
decade straight and that directly
impacts both crime and the economy until
we fix our schools we're going to keep
having these problems and again you know
the issue here with the schools is we've
got restorative justice you know credit
recovery we've got to fix our schools
and that will help fix our economy and
inflation and everything else
mr gilbert thank you mr heller you now
have 60 seconds to answer the same
question what would your plan be as
governor to curb inflation in our state
well what uh what nevadans need is
relief you're not getting any relief out
of washington dc
my plan i have an economic plan i'd sure
like to hear what the other people on
the stage have to say about their
economic plan but we need to cut taxes
here in the state of nevada when's the
last time your government cut your taxes
i want to cut sales tax by the level of
inflation that's what i want to do if
you have eight and a half percent
inflation i want to cut our sales tax by
the same amount
we got to reduce the the the pain and
suffering that's going on you go outside
uh and look at these marquis and look at
the price of gasoline i saw 699 at south
lake tahoe this week i mean this is bad
it's not five dollars a gallon it'll
beat six dollars by the middle of summer
seven by this november that we are in a
tough place we can't even get formula
for children at this point and people
can't afford food think about that right
now the average family here in the state
of nevada is going to pay 3 500 more
this year than last year next year it's
going to be 5 200 more that
next year than last year i mean this is
going to get worse and worse we need
relief we need a governor that will give
relief to these uh
to these families so mr heller a quick
follow-up here would you be open to
perhaps the spending or eliminating the
gas tax then absolutely absolutely in
fact that has been my proposal gasoline
over four dollars a gallon we will
suspend the gasoline tax that's about 65
cents a gallon here in southern nevada
about 95 cents up in northern nevada
absolutely that is the answer we need
relief i also want to eliminate the
commerce tax so we're going to give
relief to businesses and hard-working
nevada families all right thank you mr
heller now mr lee you have 60 seconds
for the same question what would your
plan be to curb inflation thank you i
understand the
struggles that the
the residents of north las vegas were
having five dollars a gallon i went to
get cereal the other day five dollars
for a box of cereal milk eggs it is
really i think there's a lot of profit
taking being taken place in this country
right now we just can't blame it all on
russia
i do know that in north las vegas we
don't want to export our children out of
our community because we we are becoming
an economic powerhouse here we've got
1800 different units now that are being
built that are that children can start
new families can come here and start
building
a life together when they first get
married
in north las vegas we were able to look
at what we could do to reduce taxes as
the social contract says it's my job to
make sure that that if you give me taxes
i help you out all i can to give you the
services you want so we did we we don't
raise fees in fact as we cut our sewer
fees 30 percent so i just want to know i
signed the no no
no tax pledge no no tax pledge increase
i just want to know did every joe did
you sign that yet have you signed the no
tax pledge yet
well we'll get list mr lombardo to
answer that in just a moment right now
it's mr norah's turn to answer the same
question you have 60 seconds what would
your plan be as governor to curb
inflation inflation happens when too
much money chases too few goods
and what's happened in the united states
of america under the current president
is that we just
released so much money under the guise
of
the trillions and trillions of coveted
relief and we caused that situation
washington caused that situation
nevadans have to pay the price for that
unfortunately
definitely the tax gas is something i
would look at
because that just makes so much sense
for us and uh i would just have it out
of there for as long as we can
but it you know you know we can't escape
the policies
of of the nation
as nevadans we live unfortunately with
the results of them and inflation is
just that
i could have told you
if we keep pumping money like we are
we're going to have inflation
and smart people were saying that
already
but
that's not what happened unfortunately
mr norah thank you so now mr lombardo
you have the final remarks on this what
would your plan be as governor to curb
inflation in our state you've got 60
seconds well first and foremost is reach
out to the president tell them to stop
printing money obviously inflation is
directly related to an over abundance of
money and the interest rates have to be
commensurate to whatever the money is
being printed and what we saw was on the
fear
and the back end of covid by our failure
of our governor to reopen the economy we
are experiencing the result of that we
are detrimental more than any other
state in the union because of his lack
of response by the current governor what
can the governor do expand upon the
economy make it conducive for companies
to come into the state of nevada with a
stable tax platform and make it
wages commensurate to the inflation
increases so they can have a quality of
life associated that you meant denise
you mentioned affordable housing how do
we address affordable housing it's not
rig control what it is is an increase in
inventory tax credits to builders for
low-income housing and to ensure that we
have the education the labor force to
occupy those jobs
mr lombardo thank you for that and
vanessa has our next question
thank you lake mead and lake powell are
both at historic lows a federal water
shortage has been declared on the
colorado river for the first time and
the federal government projects lake
mead will drop another 26 feet by the
end of next year at the same time unlv
projects clark county's population will
grow by half a million people in the
next 10 years
mr heller this question comes to you
first you have 60 seconds to answer can
nevada afford continued growth given our
dwindling water supply well first of all
the comment that the sheriff made about
now
by not supporting rent control is wrong
he said he would consider rent control
in a previous interview and i think that
would be a disaster for the economy here
in the state of nevada having said that
talking about water i think southern
nevada has done a great job in
conservation
we have also a lot of ideas of how we're
going to get more water down the
colorado river
we have here in southern nevada banked
probably 10 to 20 years worth of water
when i was back in washington dc we took
a look at the at the colorado river
compact trying to figure out the
reallocation of this water more for
nevada look what's going on in arizona
and california i think desalinization is
part of the solution let's get more
water into california we could
reallocate the water that goes on uh
into uh
into california keep this in mind the
colorado river used to go into mexico it
no longer goes there and that just goes
to show you how difficult this process
is what we need to do to conserve water
we're doing a great job here in southern
nevada and i do think we have 10 to 20
good years of banked water in order for
this community to thrive thank you mr
heller mr lombardo we will come to you
for this question about water but real
quick 15 seconds did you want to respond
to mr heller
yeah it's easy for somebody to throw
shots like that
when you when you say a global statement
like that i'll take it under
consideration without the knowledge base
to respond to it it's appropriate to
educate yourself before you make a flip
and answer and i gave my answer tonight
so you agree and you said it okay let's
move on to mr lee
mr lee can nevada afford continued
growth given our dwindling water supply
60 seconds yes ma'am so i was on the
southern nevada water authority board
for a while and conservation is the
greatest thing that we can do if we
could get other people on the colorado
river to do that alongside us it would
be great
right now we are
we're water banking in arizona we have
eight years of water as
senator hiller said eight years of water
in arizona we can use mexico if we could
get them to consider desalinization then
we would go in probably for 15 percent
arizona going for 15
we have to do things outside of
california now i know right now that
huntington beats a 15-year study
and now the environmentalists have put
that into court again you know so and
what we're doing in north las vegas with
our building codes is we're making sure
we get rid of all the swamp coolers
we're getting ready everything that
doesn't allow water to go down a sewer
and into a drain to be cleaned up so we
are doing extra in north las vegas to
make sure that we can continue to keep
the industrial market moving for better
jobs 21st century jobs i should say in
our city thank you mr lee mr nora can
nevada afford continued growth given our
dwindling water supply 60 seconds
yeah so you always have to look at these
things as an as a holistic situation you
can't just look at them one by one
because these are very large problems
that we're dealing with so so people
like me we like to think outside the box
that's what we try to do when when we're
trying to solve problems so of course
desalinization makes a lot of sense and
it's something we've got to be able to
figure out the second thing is when it
comes to some of our industries here uh
the state of israel has done an amazing
job
in the desert creating water resources
and doing that so i think it's something
we can copy now i have done technology
transfer from israel in my previous job
and i know how to do that with regards
to this particular technology as well
been there done that the last thing is
sometimes you want to think a little bit
outside the box i hear a lot about
people talking about hey the mississippi
the mississippi floods all the time is
there a way that we can get some of
their flooding flooded water
why not let's give it a try we got
nothing to lose
that's how i look at things
thank you
mr lombardo can nevada afford continued
growth given our dwindling water supply
you have 60 seconds yes if we do not
expand the economy diversify the economy
we'll die
gambling isn't getting it across the
board every state in the nation is
looking for gambling to solve their
problems in order to diversify the
economy and expand upon the economy we
have to grow
senator heller mentioned the colorado
river pack yes it's negotiation in 2026.
the governor needs to get directly
engaged in that negotiation and ensure
that we get our fair share especially
from the state of california
in the remediation levels we are treated
unfairly and that is a result of 1922
when it was negotiated there was no
population in southern nevada but
obviously there is now for us and you
can't treat the state as a whole as
uh gee nor describe it the state the
state is separated north south and the
rurals the rules need to become more
efficient in their agricultural pieces
the northern nevada needs to catch the
runoff of the waters with the build out
of reservoir systems and in southern
nevada we have to support our
congressional delegation in the
recycling coming out of southern
california thank you mr gilbert can
nevada afford continued growth given our
dwindling water supply you have 60
seconds right now nevada's in a water
crisis we will not be able to sustain
the growth that's coming to nevada if we
don't do something to do something quick
70 percent of nevada's water is spent in
agricultural about 18 percent has been
personal use another 8 percent has been
in mining
and talking with some companies out of
israel we could do a much better job
irrigating more efficiently flood
irrigating is one of the worst things we
could do we could save between 40 to 60
percent of that 70 percent if we work
with partners like that in agriculture
on top of that we're letting california
take nearly seven times their allotment
from the colorado river we need to shut
that down there's desalination we're
talking about which would be which would
definitely be an option but there's
other technology like weather
modification cloud seeding the military
has used it for 50 60 years that could
fill up these reservoirs in two to three
months not two to three years we got to
think outside the box it's time for a
businessman entrepreneur someone who's
been successful across the board not
just in government to get in there and
do what needs to be done and that's
exactly what i would do
thank you steve has the next question
well there are a record number of
migrants coming across our border with
mexico this year the biden
administration plans to lift a covet-era
health order known as title 42 although
last week a federal judge put it on hold
republicans and democrats have said it
will allow even more people seeking
asylum to come into the united states
now some governors even from states that
do not share a border with mexico have
sent members of the national guard to
the u.s mexico border to assist in
border security mr lee you're first with
this question and you have 60 seconds to
answer would you activate and send
nevada national guard troops to the
southern border
first off
that's a very good question every 15
days 275 000 people are coming across
the border into our country that's as
big as north las vegas is just so you
can get an understanding of what we're
creating we don't have the services we
don't have the schools we don't have the
health care to take care of all these
people i would put my
national guard people at risk
of
the state issues to send them down to
the border to see what we could do to
slow down what's going on with that
migrating the the the 42 thing we got to
make sure that people coming in here are
not sick and they come in legally but we
need to stop those migrants from coming
they're going to overwhelm us and our
whole quality of life is going to go
down in the united states
thank you mr lee mr nora would you
activate and send national guard troops
to the southern border so as you
probably know my parents were legal
immigrants
and
you know we went through the rules and
as do millions of people all over the
world that follow the rules from
everywhere whether it's africa or asia
or latin america to come into this
country legally
the fact that our federal government
does not enforce
our border laws
is just horrifying to me because
i seen people stand in line
everywhere i've seen how much how long
it takes
so it's just
as states
you know we're stuck with a federal
government that doesn't do their job
and to answer your question yes i would
send the
my
national guard out there
to help but that's just you know that's
just a band-aid we need to fix this
problem our federal government when i'm
governor every day the federal
government is going to hear from me hey
it's genora from nevada fix this problem
you're killing us
thank you mr noura mr lombardo would you
activate to send nevada national guard
troops to the border no
there's a finite amount of money i was
actually a
military officer in the nevada national
guard there's a finite amount of money
associated with the deployment of your
local state guard and if you deploy them
to the border that money would dry up
quickly and it would be prevent them
from responding to any crisis associated
within the borders of our state
what we need to do is force the hand of
the federal government obviously
immigration is a federal issue
we need to support within the state the
removal of individuals who have
committed crimes
and
present them to ice accordingly
i support
legal immigration i do not support
illegal immigration and i am the only
one standing up here at this podium that
has removed anybody who has committed
crimes associated with and being
undocumented illegal within the state of
nevada thank you mr lamar mr gilbert
same question to you would you deploy
troops to the southern border absolutely
without a doubt i would deploy the
troops but unfortunately sheriff
lombardo you know we refer to him among
us as sanctuary joe for a reason
department of justice inspector
general's report 2016 had clark county
is one of the worst
sanctuary counties in the nation on may
31st 2016 it was labeled one of ten
jurisdictions that was found in
violation of federal law for not turning
over illegal immigrants to ice
now nevada has the highest illegal
immigrant population per capita in the
nation 223 thousand we all know it's
much higher than that that's a direct
you know effect from not enforcing the
law and that took place right here since
2014 things have just been out of
control with regards to sanctuary city
it's exploded the crime rate by 500
percent so we have to do something if we
don't send you know help down to the
border it's going to continue to affect
us in a negative way we can't sustain it
what's going on here right now so we
absolutely must do something and i would
send our guard down there thank you mr
gilbert mr lombardo you were invoked
there for a minute
30 seconds to reply is nevada is las
vegas a sanctuary city no sanctuary's
determination comes out of the state
legislature and our legislature has not
identified or
labeled any jurisdiction within the
state of nevada's sanctuary
the removal of undocumented felonious
immigrants is done within the local
sheriff's jurisdiction and ability and
within southern nevada i do that on a
regular basis more so than any other
county in the state of nevada and it's
incumbent upon the resources available
via ice
and their ability to take those
individuals into custody and remove them
and the 500 percent
that is a fictitious number that mr
gilbert presented thank you mr lombardo
mr heller uh you're you have 60 seconds
to answer the full question would you
send nevada national guard troops to the
board i would but let's let's be clear
joe's not telling the truth here
what happened when he made southern
nevada a sanctuary city if you want to
live in a dangerous neighborhood live in
a sanctuary city and that's what this
guy costs you don't have to have the
legislature deem us a sanctuary city
what you do is you have a sheriff like
this guy that kicks ice out of metro and
not only does he do that he practices
catch and release
and those illegal immigrants that
committed crimes he's putting back on
the street this is the problem that we
have here in southern nevada this guy
needs to tell the truth and actually own
up to it we have a 50 percent increase
in homicides we have a 45 percent
increase in violent crimes here in clark
county all because of this guy deciding
that he wanted southern nevada to be a
sanctuary city and this has to stop
because it's affecting everywhere else
in the state northern nevada washoe elko
winnemucca elko now has drugs and gangs
because this guy is bringing these
illegal immigrants into this state and
spreading them across the state thank
you mr heller again mr lombardo you've
been uh attacked uh the the crime
statistics are they related to
the immigration issue absolutely not you
can't draw a line to the immigration
issue at all in the crime statistics and
as far as the homicide rate we are down
currently down three percent in totality
and homicide if you look at the joining
jurisdictions north las vegas and
henderson you can't say that and i have
not kicked ice out of our jail in our
system we present individuals from the
jail to ice
ice makes the determination whether they
take them what we did do is we got sued
by the aclu and we lost the use of the
federal database to identify these
individuals and as a result we email
them and we make phone calls there is no
change in the procedures the national
picture has
lackened the resources associated for
removal
thank you thank you mr water we'll we'll
have more time later in the debate but
our next question is denise
in just a moment
gentlemen
now and then we'll come back during your
closing remarks you can go ahead and
come back to the doctor general's
reports available on my website gilbert
all right mr gilbert thank you so now
moving on to each candidate's individual
question we are keeping the same order
so um mr nora gets the first question
here tonight uh you have been successful
as a venture capitalist and you've been
a
successful business background as well
you have said that that business
background will help you govern the
state however you would certainly need
the support of a very likely democratic
legislature so you have a 60 seconds
here to answer since you have no
government experience how would you get
anything done if elected as governor
so
first and foremost
when you've been a venture capitalist
like i have
if you think that the legislature is a
problem try working with other venture
capitalists
okay they're the smartest people in the
room
and usually they are
and they know everything better than
everybody else and that was just in my
partnership
now think about the investments that was
involved in outside of my partnerships
where we had boards of directors
consisting of seven or eight to nine
people
so i think dealing with the actual
people in in carson city
is going to be
easy for me having dealt what i've dealt
with before
and it takes an outsider
so i'm not going to come in with the
biases even the bias that you just say
well yeah it's going to be hard to work
with these people it's a total opposite
i come in with nothing to lose and a lot
to gain for the people in nevada
i'm working for them i'm not working the
system i'm not a politician i'm just
trying to solve problems for the people
in nevada and that's what i'm going to
be doing and that's how i will do it
mr nora thank you vanessa has our next
individual question
thank you this next question is for mr
lombardo kevin mcmahill is running for
clark county sheriff the position you
currently hold he was your second in
command at the department before he
retired and you've endorsed him to
replace you as sheriff in 1995 when
kevin mcmahill was a metro police
officer
a fellow metro officer says she
witnessed mcmahill and his partner
commit misconduct during a stop
following the incident mcmahill failed a
polygraph we're going to play part of an
8 news now i-team report they made me
come over by their car and lift my skirt
and
show my privates
and then they took me to the front of
the car
and they went through my purse and they
found a small amount of
crack cocaine
and they said if i wanted to go
that i would have to eat that did you
ever ask a woman
while you were working as an officer to
see her genitals never i'm an irish guy
i wear my my emotion on my sleeve i was
huffing and puffing and i was very upset
before i ever got hooked up to that box
no chance in hell that i ever passed
that test
mr lombardo you have 60 seconds to
answer do you believe kevin mcmahill's
two female accusers
well all i know is that
one particular i don't know anything
about the other female accuser the one
female accuser has been
impeached
for lack of integrity and another case
that i've become aware of and quite
often i got asked questions first of all
i think this is a ridiculous question it
has nothing to do with running for the
state of nevada for the governor's
position
and
but i will opine on it and i will to
discuss it because you're questioning my
ability to endorse this individual i
believe that's the direction you're
going with this and i support kevin
mcmahon 100 percent this is an incident
that took place 25 years ago and he went
through the due process associated with
that and he was cleared associated with
those crimes he had worked for three
previous sheriffs prior to me before
rising up into the ranks and then i
eventually made a decision to make
undersheriff and he did a fantastic job
during his tenure as the undersheriff
mr lombardo thank you you mentioned
she was impeached have you seen
documentation to show that in 30 seconds
yes i have
okay thank you denise has the next
question moving on now to mr gilbert you
have called to reopen the investigation
into the one october shooting saying on
your facebook page cover-up where's the
money who was in that room mr gilbert
you have 60 seconds to answer what do
you think about the one october shooting
was covered up
it's very simple you know i spent a lot
of time first of all i lived in las
vegas from 2003 until 2008 i opened a
business down here 2013 through 16. a
lot of friends down here and every time
i'm down here someone brings up the
route 91 shooting
whether it's the money or whether it's
finding out who was all in that room
they don't believe that the
investigation was done properly i've
even met with metro officers and they've
all said that at the end of the day that
there's just you know the the it has
there hasn't been full transparency on
what took place there's timelines that
are off there's you know things that are
you know we look at witness statements
you look at video and again i've i've
dug in as much as i can i do not have
the knowledge that you know others do so
as i've said you know and i've said this
numerous times i reserve that from once
i'm in as governor and i can take a look
at it at the end of the day i'm not
going to call anybody's integrity into
question but i'll just say that it's
been told to me numerous times that
there was not necessarily a cover-up but
people haven't been forthright there's
not enough transparency and i said as
governor to get to the bottom of it i
think nevadans are due and answer five
years later if there's still questions
so uh mr lombardi were cleared out
they're talking about the fact that he
doesn't feel there was transparency he
has questions about this investigation
mr lombardo let me give you a moment to
reply to that
yeah thank you for the opportunity well
i was directly
involved in that incident as you can
imagine and i lived it for several years
even today
and for people to
pune my officer's integrity and the
investigation associated with that is
ridiculous and i i stand by them in all
aspects of that investigation and to
include the allegations that i embezzled
along with um mr sisilak 30 million
dollars associated that with that for
the victims
we have posted on my website the
distribution of that money to disprove
those allegations every day i'm
presented with individuals based with
joey gilbert's campaign accusing me of
an improper investigation a cover-up a
conspiracy and
embezzling the 30 million dollars we
have posted the full investigation
different than any police department
entire nation in this aspect involving a
mass shooting the full investigation is
posted on the lvmpd website in full
color for people to fully review mr
lombardo thank you for that steve
mr heller this next question is for you
back in 2006 you told the review journal
that you were pro-choice in january of
this year you said you were pro-life in
2017 you said at a town hall that you'd
protect planned parenthood and had no
problem with federal funding for it the
next day your campaign clarified that
you opposed funding for planned
parenthood so mr heller the question is
this and you have 60 seconds to reply
how can voters trust that the positions
you're taking today will be the same
positions you take if you're elected
well first of all i am pro-life and i'm
proud of it let's get that clear and
some of those questions or concerns that
you brought up uh i was probably more
libertarian at the time when i when when
i
kind of kept a hands-off situation here
when it came to the abortion question
when i got to congress i had to make a
decision and i have an a plus rating
with the nevada right to life and the
national right to life i have always
voted uh
consistently in the uh in that
manner having said that the planned
parenthood comment yes i have to admit
that i i misspoke i was talking about
mammograms and women's health not
funding for planned parenthood i have my
record is very very clear 100
having voted against any funding for
planned parenthood my record will
continue uh when i am governor of this
state to be pro-life i am proud of the
fact that we have two supreme court
justices back in washington d.c that are
going to overturn roe v wade kavanaugh
and gorsuch and i voted for both of them
to bring this issue back to the state of
nevada because it's time for us to have
a discussion here in the state of nevada
and where we want to go
on this particular issue thank you mr
heller vanessa
thank you the next question is for mr
lee on april 10th a firearms instructor
made racist comments at a training event
for concealed weapons permits you were
sitting in the front row at the time
let's take a look at a brief clip
always leave the chicken grease on your
fingers
always make sure there's a white person
around so you have someone to blame for
everything
[Applause]
mr lee you have 60 seconds you are the
only republican running for office in
attendance that hasn't publicly
commented on that presentation here's
your opportunity tonight yeah so while i
was sitting there and that was like 10
12 seconds whatever it was and i was on
the front wall because i want to learn
as much as i could this was an
opportunity for me to understand the ccw
laws and he made those stupid statements
and after the event i went up to him and
said you should never do that if you
want to be a successful businessman you
need to learn how to curb your mouth you
need to learn how to curb your
presentation now when people started
calling me it's not my job to try to run
him out of business it's not my job to
to to follow the press and and follow
along and do what they want me to say
and do i had a private conversation with
him but why was i getting a ccw that was
the thing i was there because
north las vegas we used to be number one
in crime we're not anymore i put 10 more
million dollars in the budget we have
200 more police officers we open our
jail and so right now we're number four
in crime we've got metro joe lombardo
sparks reno and then us as is where the
crime is i went on the strip the other
day it smelled like everybody smoked
marijuana there just felt so dangerous i
thought i might need to get a ccw if i'm
getting gas and some of these goofy
people are coming out the strip and i
need to protect my family so that's why
i was getting ccw
thank you mr lee and to clarify you
mentioned you spoke privately with the
instructor but again to clarify 15
seconds did you find that offensive yeah
i did and that's why i went up it's like
when people take a a picture with me and
they have a beer in their hand it puts
me in a position i don't want to be in
that gentleman heard for me but he
didn't have to hear me tell you how bad
he was i had already told him that i'm
not in for destroying people that are
running businesses i want to make sure
they're successful but they learn they
need to stop doing it they want to be
successful thank you denise has the next
question all right gentlemen so we are
going back now to questions for all of
the candidates the u.s supreme court may
overturn roe v wade and lead the
decision on abortion up to the
individual states now nevada law
currently allows abortion up to 24 weeks
into a pregnancy and later if the health
of the mother is threatened now our law
would have to be changed by vote by the
public now that does leave some room for
other laws to be passed so first off in
this question tonight is mr lambargo you
were first you have 60 seconds would you
support perhaps adding parental
notification laws waiting periods before
ending a pregnancy or other restrictions
maybe like on the plan b pills mr
lombardo yes absolutely i would take
that on into consideration first and
foremost i'm a pro-life
individual i plan to lead as a pro-life
governor and any legislation that would
come or bill or resolution that would
come before my desk i would look at it
with a pro-life lens
with that being said i would take under
into consideration anything associated
with the pro-life
view
moving forward
is there anything specific that you
might consider if it came across your
desk not at this time no
all right let's move on to mr gilbert
the same question
do you support any additional abortion
restrictions 60 seconds no i'm first
first and foremost i'm pro-life and
i'm against abortion personally
at the end of the day nevada has
ingrained in our statutory you know law
and protected by the constitution
through the statutory law the right to
choose in this state if anything i would
like to see it rolled back to 20 weeks
but again that's not something for a
governor something would be going before
the people we would put that to a vote
of the people and our elected
representatives
i do think though that we do need things
like age and limits you know right now
because of governor sislak he's taken
away you know parental consent and again
you know if you look at what's happening
here in nevada where the number two and
number five per capita sex trafficking
in child sex trafficking hubs in the
united states and what who are those
young kids getting taken and young women
getting taken in those are girls that
are being sex trafficked and if they can
then be brought in for an abortion
without consent that's dangerous it's
something we don't want to do we don't
want to become an abortion state and so
i would take those protections as
governor for sure mr gilbert thank you
mr heller i know you touched on this
topic a moment ago but uh would you
support any additional abortion
restrictions to our current nevada law
well first of all i think the last two
candidates that just spoke uh basically
uh said they're pro-choice uh when uh
when you say that you're gonna support
the laws that we have a place
but i'm pro-life i think that makes you
pro-choice um and that
is in anybody's definition as i
mentioned i uh supported both gorsuch
and kavanaugh
when i was in in the senate and
and their votes are going to overturn
roe v wade and it's going to come to the
state and i'm going to do everything i
possibly can to make nevada a pro-life
state
i don't like the 24 uh 24 weeks i want
to reduce that obviously parental
consent all of those issues that that
you're talking about i am pro-life and
i'm proud of it and i want nevada to be
a pro-life state and i do not want to
make nevada a sanctuary state for
abortions that that cannot happen here
in the state of nevada and i will keep
that from happening is there something
specific though that you might consider
yeah yeah i will do whatever it takes
i'll do whatever it takes i i will
introduce legislation in fact i will
raise the money necessary to overturn
the uh the abortion statutes that we
have here in the state of nevada if it
takes two or three million dollars to
create it to to raise the money to get
it back on the ballot because i realize
that's the only way it can change that's
what i will do i want to move nevada in
the right direction right now we're in
the wrong direction all right reference
do you reference me and i think it's
only fair i get to respond mr gabriel
i'll give you 15 seconds just to clarify
that just very quickly you know i toured
the women's resource medical center and
in nevada having the opportunity you
know we need to work with faith-based
leaders we need with parents children
teach the sanctity of human life we do
need to do a better job as a community
and that's something i would focus on
but again at the end of the day as i
said nevada is a is a is a pro-choice
state and we would have to respect that
all right mr lee at the same question 60
seconds would you support any additional
abortion restrictions no i won't i will
fight to save those little babies lives
they are blessings from father in heaven
i have seven children 30 grandchildren
and one great grandchild with another
coming i'm excited about this life the
problem we have is the abortion issue in
the state of nevada sometimes there's
not a system that allows these mothers
to do the right thing and they think
this is their only option
i believe in the heartbeat bill i
believe that little baby is at the
moment there's a heartbeat that's a baby
and i would fight to to get us back to
that point there
for 14 years with the nevada right to
life organization i was a-rated
by them
i do believe though if it's rape the
life of the mother or incest that is a
family issue but i just want to go on
the record is the legislature will know
not to send something to me that has
nothing to do with protecting life
instead of killing life thank you mr lee
thank you and we wrap up this question
tonight with mr nora again as a reminder
you have 60 seconds do you support any
additional abortion restrictions in
nevada
so i am pro-life and i will tell you why
as you probably know
when i was 15 i was in a civil war
and when you've taken lives
and you've seen lives taken
you become pro-life
and that's my experience
and i usually stop right there
on that subject
any specific
restrictions that you might consider
though
you know it's going to have to come
through the people
through the legislature
and i'll decide then but you know my
bias
okay thank you sir
our next question becomes from steve
gentlemen we want to make sure we have
time for closing statements so the
answers to these questions will be 30
seconds instead of the usual 60 seconds
the topic is education
the national chamber of commerce says
our education system is the second worst
in the country in the first six months
of this year clark county school
district has had more than five thousand
violent incidents now substitute
teachers at ccsd only need to have a
high school diploma to be called in to
work with children so mr gilbert we'll
start with you you have 30 seconds to
answer this question what are your
specific plans to fix the clark county
school district it's very simple we need
to remove restorative justice credit
recovery the absenteeism and the drug
use far too much violence is taking
place the teachers are leaving the
profession at record numbers they feel
like no one's supporting them we need to
go to the to teachers union there's less
than 50 percent of the teachers in the
union now tell them they better start
backing the teachers we decertify the
unions we're in a full crisis here in
nevada something must be done because
our children are not being educated and
they're far more danger in far more
danger than they ever been before
parents are scared to drop them off at
school teachers are afraid to go to
school and if we don't act soon soon
enough it's going to create a problem
that's going to be around here for
generations thank you mr gilbert mr
heller same question 30 seconds uh
fixes for the clark county school
district let's be clear we have a
governor that in his first term spent
half his time shutting the schools down
that's why we have second graders i
can't read third graders i can't write
fourth graders who can't do arithmetic
this has to stop we have to get more
more adults into colleges getting their
degrees in education twenty years ago
twenty percent of the people in colleges
got a education degree do you know today
it's two percent two percent we can't
get teachers into the schools we need to
pay them more we need to make sure that
they're safe make sure that the crt is
not taught make sure that they're that
kindergartners aren't learning sex
education we need to back the school
districts but we need school board
members that are conservative and that
care about the parents more than they
care about the schools themselves mr
howell i appreciate that mr lee same
question in 30 seconds the clark county
school district yeah in north las vegas
we've got more charter schools private
schools and parochial schools than
anywhere else in this valley our parents
want educational opportunities we have
42 schools in north las vegas that's
enough to have our own school district
we believe in north las vegas that we
want to work with education at a closer
level
we want local control we want our own
school trustees we want to pull away
where we can compete like we are with
these charter schools to be able to
allow those children to come to us and
we will retain and recruit teachers
better if north las vegas is in charge
of it rather than the conglomerate
school district thank you mr lee mr
north same question in 30 seconds you
know education has been an issue in the
state since 1998 i was reading a book
kenny guinn was talking about education
way back when
it hasn't worked whatever they've done
has not worked so you need somebody from
the outside who's going to come in and
look at this as a restart that's what we
do in the world in the real world in the
business world we look at these things
that restarts for me the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to have
an education summit everybody who's a
stakeholder in education is going to
come in
sit down with the governor i'll buy the
pizza
and we're going to hang around until we
get a solution because this is not
acceptable by any means
power to parents is trying to help
there's lots of organizations that are
being involved right now to help
and that's what it's going to take it's
going to take all of us
thank you sir appreciate it mr lombardo
you wrap this up 30 seconds fixes for
the clark county school district
clark county school district specific
is that it's steve yes okay well you
know it all works together the economy
the safety of our communities and
education have to work together for the
success and the entirety of the state
and specific to clark county school
district
mr gilbert alluded to it restorative
justice it is a failed program brought
forward by the legislature and the
current superintendent and the governor
who provides the vision via the
department of education has failed to
act on it as a result of that kids
aren't comfortable in learning kids
aren't comfortable and going to schools
teachers aren't comfortable in being
there
we have to change that paradigm sooner
than later thank you sir appreciate it
denise
all right gentlemen so now we will move
on to our closing remarks uh actually in
reverse order of our poll each of you
will have 30 seconds to wrap up and we
begin tonight with closing remarks from
mr nora
so 45 years ago
to this day
i was a 15 year old
carrying an ak-47 in beirut lebanon
fighting for my people
and their freedom
i stand in front of you today
a successful businessman who's lived the
american dream
and i'm running for governor so that
each and everyone in nevada has the
opportunity to live the american dream
i tell my kids when i do my counseling
on music i've got your back
as your governor i will have your back
nevadans
i will be honored to have your vote as
well thank you
thank you mr norah now also for our
closing remarks we move to mr lee again
as a reminder you have 30 seconds here
yeah i appreciate that
um
you know north las vegas when i took
over as mayor was going to have to get
back its charter and so i was elected if
you had ten more dollars ten dollars in
your wallet you had 10 more dollars
north than the state of nevada had
pardoned me we got in there we brought
our conservative business values in
there we brought people in there that
were smart we we got government out of
the way we learned how to use this
system and understood we were competing
against henderson las vegas and
clark county and so what we did is we
provided more jobs because of that i
think good government is the way to
handle these things and not poor
business practices and that's what our
city of north las vegas is doing i can
fix nevada
none of these guys can i will
mr lee thank you now we move on to mr
heller for your closing remarks again 30
seconds all right what nevada needs is a
proven conservative i've spent a career
cutting taxes reducing the size of
government and looking for relief for
nevada's nevadans hard-working families
what are we going to get in november do
you want a proven conservative or do you
want somebody who's best friends with
steve sislak sheriff lombardo and steve
sisselak contribute to each other's
campaigns they raise money for each
other they sit on each other's
transitions as transition committees i
mean this is ridiculous that we have two
people identical sisilak and lombardo
when you can actually have a proven
conservative that has cut taxes who's
reduced the size of government who's pro
who is pro-life we have an opportunity
to make a real difference here in the
state of nevada in this election all
right mr heller thank you now we move on
to mr gilbert for your closing remarks
thank you first and foremost in clark
county we need to you know break up the
school district and secondly we need
school vouchers education vouchers
statewide unless the public schools are
forced to compete for students they have
no incentive to improve that being said
i've proven the past 27 months i've been
fighting for nevadans on my own time in
my own time i got the churches open i
got early treatment medication the mass
off the children and we're appealing
that one to the ninth circuit again the
american quality american you know
american dream in american quality of
life is only safe with someone that's
actually going to step up leadership is
actually not a position i've proven that
i'll keep proving that and i look
forward to being our next governor mr
gilbert thank you and mr lombardo you
get the opportunity to make your closing
room right let's be honest with each
other for all practical purposes this
primary is over
there's nothing more to argue about i've
weathered 12 months of attacks from
steve cyslak in his packs and for most
of the individuals standing here next to
me
and why why why have i been able to work
weather them they're all bogus they're
not working and the reason why they're
not working is because i'm leading in
all the polls i have the most money
associated with the successful campaign
i have the endorsement of president
donald trump and i have the endorsement
of 16 of 17 sheriffs
so we need to call get come together we
need to go after syslax cislac is the
problem he has ruined our economy he has
ruined our schools he's ruined our
safety and i'm the only one that has the
leadership and experience that nevadans
can trust mr lombardo thank you and
thanks to all of our candidates tonight
that's our time and thank you for
watching our republican primary
gubernatorial debate we want to thank
all the candidates for participating
tonight mail-in ballots are already
arriving early voting starts may 28th
and ends june 10th primary day as a
reminder is june 14th